is it hard to make friends when you're
like a transfer student i think it's
impossible to make friends
that's such a lie would have you believe
that the transfer students yeah they're
like
everyone wants everyone wants to know
the transfer student big surprise here
and
i and i'm gonna give you a huge reality
check but as an anime singer
anime is not exactly real
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i am your host for today
gant and joining me as usual
are the boys and once again i am hosting
another guest
do you want to introduce yourself and
tell us what you do or tell the viewers
what you do i should say
sure um hi my name is nano um you
probably don't know who i
am but nice to meet you nice to meet you
guys very
very humble start yeah i have to say you
were the only reason why i loved batum
so much oh really yeah
yeah zoom opening is so goddamn good
oh really yeah honestly from like that
especially batoon but out of everything
about the tomb
i still remember the opening yeah to the
stage yeah to this day
and it's impressive because i don't
remember a lot about that show
it's uh it's been it's been many it's
it's been it's been many many years but
i still
the opening just [ __ ] bang i just
gotta i gotta say that and also arpeggio
blue steel opening
is like so freaking good okay i do
remember that show
being quite bad but the opening though
you know yeah opening spanx even though
i'm really i'm often mocked because i i
can't really appreciate music
but i have to admit your music i like
the noise that is an
honor to hear that it's an honor so do
you want to introduce yourself a little
to the viewers so they can learn a bit
more about you and
you um well you know as they said um
i've sung a couple
openings for anime uh anime
series
um because talking is not my job so you
know i mean yeah you you sing sing
you have a much more lovely voice than
we do we just talk [ __ ] all day yeah and
that's our job
exactly but you know today is my uh sort
of youtube w days oh wow
oh you're debuting today yes so maybe
i'm gonna be a youtuber
youtuber from now on i did see you did a
youtube live stream at one point
i did i did i would love to do more
stuff on youtube so this today is sort
of my challenge day and i'm
really looking forward to uncovering a
new
sort of me and you saw it yourself
yes exciting new adventure yeah the
amount of pressure
adventure that's going to be my new uh
song lyric oh wow
but yeah cause i was curious like oh
obviously you've done
anime openings and you do uh your own
original music but how did you get your
start in that
ah that's a really long thing you really
want to go there yeah yeah sure
we got the time let's just jump right
into it i thought about looking at the
wikipedia page
i want to be like the viewer and
experience everything about it yeah
exactly
yeah that's great though tells
everything yeah yeah don't don't go to
wiki
get your information from the real story
firsthand
yes well um i started off um well i've
always wanted to become a singer
since i was little but i started off
actually on the internet so i was an
internet singer i did a lot of youtube
right that that goes back way back to
history um even before all this like
youtube boom happened
i was a youtuber what year what yeah
what year i got asked what year
um way back when it's like 2 000
in like back when you had to favorite
the videos and give five stars
yes and like no matter what you did you
never got money for it
yeah that you know so back when it was a
four by three
yeah right aspect ratio oh oh gee
youtuber brilliant
is that when you started can't i mean
i've i started at kind of the beginning
of youtube so
yeah like 2006 right 2007.
so youtube launched in 2006 and i made
my first
it was late 2000s so i was you know
just on youtube i did my own original
songs uploaded videos
and then i started you know japan
started
getting into the um sort of movie
internet into like the culture of
everything
full japanese half i'm full japanese i
was born and raised in america my
parents are both japanese so i'm kind of
a hybrid
so bilingual as well bilingual but i'd
say i'm
like my roots are the stronger roots are
america
so i still find a lot of japanese things
really like
crazy insane
i mean we've talked about the weird
things we find about japanese culture
all the time
i'm sure i saw that video this morning i
watched it before coming here
so i'm good to go
probably did more research than us i
feel bad now
well i mean i because like you know
connor's the kind of person who's like i
don't read the wikipedia i'd rather just
hear it from the person but like
i thought i would just dive slightly
into the wikipedia and kind of
ask you that's a lot
but like i'm the kind of person who like
goes to the wikipedia and then asks the
person to confirm it if it's tricky
because
yeah you know a lot of times wikipedia
is full of [ __ ] yeah you know they just
write whatever the hell yeah
i don't think i've ever even checked my
own wikipedia because i'm scared
of responding to expectations oh no i
completely get it i've i've checked we
have
we don't i don't have a wikipedia i have
like a youtube wiki or something
the amount of misinformation on that is
just off the scale
um there's there's like there's like a
list of i think like my best friends in
order on that wiki page and it's
it is like the most watched list i've
ever seen
because they're stuffed friends yeah
exactly but like i was looking at your
wikipedia
and one part one one aspect that i
thought was really interesting was how
you got started
right and it was like you started off by
covering anime songs
vocaloid songs and then really
specifically it said
covering avril lavigne's songs
is this true well i've done a few of her
songs
yeah but i wouldn't say i'm a huge ever
living cover
yeah yeah i've done like two two songs
yeah but it's it's weird because the
wikipedia made it out to be like you
were like the ultimate
cover artist for avril lavigne yeah it's
specifically
named levine along with anime and
vocaloids
i have an ever levine genre in my
wikipedia that's
for some reason yeah i mean like but
then again like you know
when i saw that i was like okay that
kind of makes sense because
you know you you kind of do have like a
very like early 2000s like avril lavigne
like but i do love her
yeah i ended up listening to her music
but i wouldn't say i'm like
turning into an interrogation really
that's really
big for me but yeah yeah so like
what made you like upload your first
songs were you just like passing time or
did you just
was this your outlet um well there was a
time in my this is pretty deep
yeah it's pretty deep okay
my life where i was completely like
introverted i was a stay-at-home kind of
person even
before all this um corona happened in
1990 i was a stay-at-home person
right there with you yeah i mean i mean
you're preaching to the choir now yeah
so this is like my generation right now
so yeah
um yeah during that time though i still
wanted to do music i still wanted to
reach out to people
so i thought you know oh yeah internet
great that's really uh
bendy yeah and so i started
uploading my own songs and lo and behold
i realized that there was a huge crowd
out there in the world that i could
reach out to
right through the internet so that was
my start what was like your influences
for some of your early songs was it
mostly like anime and vocaloid or was it
just
or was it avril lavigne or was it yeah
there we go
definitely can't live without her but
yeah definitely um i listened to
a lot of different types of music
growing up even from disney to
like british rock american rock anime
music j-rock
like i'm a huge widespread listener so
um
i wouldn't just narrow it down to one
genre or artist
right um yeah anime was a huge uh
start for me yeah because uh anime music
was
my introduction to the japanese culture
just like you guys yeah
and so yeah i mean what what confuses me
almost is
how do you go from doing covers to then
actually being the one singing the anime
opening what's that process
how do you go from there i'd like to ask
someone that
to be honest you don't know who does it
because there's probably so
many people out there on youtube
who are just like if i just keep going i
might end up being the one singer
that's the thing like you have to just
keep on doing it because that's what i
did
and you know whether you end up where
you end up it's i don't know but if you
don't continue doing what you're doing
then you're never gonna get so did
someone scout you or did you
go you know sending in auditions or like
what was the process like to
i guess even get i guess recognized by a
company or just get signed i guess yeah
yeah before i started though i always
thought that you had to reach out you
had to go there
and get it yourself but if you keep
doing the things you do and you really
enjoy
what you're doing then you're going to
shine and people are going to listen to
you and people are going to notice you
so if it's if what you're doing is right
for you
then i think that someone out there is
going to find you
and in my case i was lucky enough to be
found by my director
who uh supported my debut so okay when
was this was this through youtube or
through nico nico
youtube right was it focused on anime or
was it just everything it was like
vocaloids at the time oh wow
i'm not a huge vocaloider to be honest
um
you know i wasn't that knowledgeable
about vocaloids but i was just covering
vocaloid songs in english
okay okay that was my big start uh
covering
vocaloid science in english
yeah i don't think you have much
competition on nico nico because they're
like i think i think there's a small
dedicated community on youtube who
translates and does
english song covers of anime songs and
uh vocaloid songs but i've never heard
anyone posting on it on
nico nico mostly because nobody can
figure nico nico out yeah
there were like two people covering
vocaloid songs in english
but those people were not native english
speakers
i was listening to that and i thought
there could be something i could do
yeah um because i'm not that great at
japanese but i'm granted english so why
don't i just do that in english and so
um
i started doing that and then the
japanese people were like oh this is new
they were like oh eggo jozu exactly
they're like why is this why is this
person
what's a toeic school
so you know that kind of sort of boosted
up my views okay
and then after that after the japanese
people started watching then
my songs started reaching out to the uh
overseas community
so um it was sort of like a i don't know
a ripple you know
out into the world yeah so would you
like would you say
that you were bigger on nico nico than
you were on youtube back in the day or
is that where you found your growth
um before i started nico nico um i was
my listeners um were more on a youtube
level but then
from nico nico uh it went like booms
yeah i think my crowd started bigger on
nico nico
because what's always what's always
fascinated me is the difference between
say
like the youtube anime culture and just
nico nico
in general i feel like it goes like a
different planet yeah it's to me as like
a western anime fan i see some of the
stuff that's going on in nico nico and
it just
one makes zero sense to me and two has
seems to have some of the most talented
creators i've like
ever seen yeah and definitely and
nobody's heard about them because
they're on this
on this one japanese website that no
foreigner can ever figure out
it's also insane with nico nico as well
because like i used to go on nico [ __ ]
quite a bit
like even before youtube and it's just
yeah as you said like
for some reason creators on nico nico
are just on a different level and none
of them like do it
you know for like ad revenue or anything
yeah they literally do it out of passion
yeah and like and you know like so many
like utaitas and like
sing and japanese singers are all found
who type that
is basically do you want to explain what
a new titan is oh you can do it
is basically like uh someone who does
like covers of
vocaloid and anime and stuff like that
basically it's like it's like youtube
has its own version of attitude it's
called you tai tas
oh i think i have heard of this yeah
yeah so basically it's just like a
uh you know an amateur singer who does
covers of anime
that's good and stuff like that and a
lot of them get you know uh major record
labels like
so how long were you uploading on nico
nico before you got like any kind of
traction
i am i was completely newbie so um there
were
so many bigger greater uh days before me
doing their thing and i just started and
i
uploaded i happened to upload my first
videos
i think it was like 2000 really late
2010 into 2011
and then 2011 early in 2011 i got
noticed by my director so it was like a
few months oh wow
and so i have no friends on youtube
um yeah and my probably uh nico nico
wikipedia thingy is really like short
and sweet i mean because you were on a
flight not even a year
i'll be honest if someone contacted me
like four months into youtube being like
listen i want to give you a record deal
i'd be like
this sounds like a scam yeah i thought
so
yeah i thought so but i got a direct um
sort of contact through a creator
oh okay so who is called a vocaloid p
uh producer so um so confusing
yeah i know the words on nico nico are
like really easy so
we're gonna go yeah i'm trying to i'm
trying to i mean it's like when you're
when you're going tick-tock you're like
what the [ __ ] is happening
why is everyone thinking what's going on
because to me i've always known about
the vocaloid community but
as someone who's quite ingrained into
the weeb culture i had
the vocaloid fad just kind of like went
and went by and i had no idea
about anything that was going on in that
community legit the only
way i could understand like half the
memes that were existent on nico nico
was to just like
bite the ball and go on two chan i'm
just like because it's all just there so
i was like
[ __ ] i guess i have to go into this
cesspool to understand it and even then
i can only understand maybe like 30
percent of it before i was like
i just don't get this i don't get this
at all yeah so like what what was the
difference between like
say nuka nuka culture and uploading to
youtube for you for yourself
um well like you said nico nico is very
like a closed community everyone is
understanding they're like
you know friends on there and it's like
a parallel universe it
are people nice on that platform very
nice very nice wow
that is a power location that okay so
um yeah but i just think that it's like
a universe in itself
so um they kind of move
along in the world at their own pace so
that was kind of different from youtube
youtube is very open
it's worldwide and there's so many
people on there
so um yeah because i feel like because
nico nico is so
focused on the kind of like the anime
and
weeb side of the community that it's it
feels much more closed off
um and especially with the japanese
speaking as well
but that that's that just makes me want
to get into it more because
it seems like an untapped gold mine are
you sure about that i mean i don't know
i don't know because i from from from
the outside looking in there seems to be
like such a gold mine of content there
especially people getting scouted
professionally on that platform just
shows that there is
real talent in that platform honestly
like some i'd say some of the best anime
based memes have
all originated from nico nico you could
make a store thing
yeah absolutely it's like still popular
is huge still yeah really yeah
it's huge especially in asia it's big
and um
i'd have to say though um the talent on
nico nico
is amazing unmatched unmatched that's
why i think all these record labels
katakawa and sneaker oh wow oh really i
didn't know that
wow thank you shout out such a great
platform
i'm not endorsed to say that at all
i'm i'm i'm curious how do you then okay
so you get signed right
how how long is it before you're you're
you know given this opportunity to voice
you know an anime opening and what are
you allowed to tell us about that
process
we have no idea where we've never heard
of like anyone's
first-hand experiences of going into
that kind of stuff oh wow yeah
um actually you know i've never actually
just really looked back and thought
deeply into this
but yeah for me i i wouldn't say that
this goes for
every artist but for me um the first
time my director contacted me
wasn't to give me a record deal or
label uh record deal to make a debut it
was to do a collaboration
on a song a cover song that was going to
be on a compliation album
okay this record label was going to
release
and so i um sort of collaborated with
them to put one song on there
and after that um the director said
okay so we've done one song together but
what about we do
a full album a debut album together
so that was sort of my start and from
there
it was about a year i think that we went
into sort of creation
of this new al my w album right
and original songs had to be made and so
um it was about a year that it took from
me
from getting um from meeting this
director until
uh releasing my first album okay so you
so this album was purely just original
songs that you had to write within that
year
yeah i did a few uh cover songs since
you know my fan base was
based on nico nico so i did a few uh
vocaloid cover songs in english
and i released a few original new songs
and then after that i released the album
and then my first single
actually came after that so my first
anime type
was uh later on a few months later okay
so was that
was recording the album as well like the
first time you were doing like studio
work or was it even
oh my gosh my first time in an actual
studio
oh my gosh that was crazy how was that
oh no no no no no that was like
nerve-wracking to the extreme oh yeah um
especially because it was big
victor studio yeah it wasn't like a
small
sort of um indie studio or anything it
was like victor's two
major record labels like multiple people
at the other side of the glass like just
watching exactly
and oh my gosh me alone um in the booth
and then all these like
official looking people giving like
direction
and everything like that it's like the
first time i voice acted in
like a proper studio because i always
used to just do it like in my house in
front of my own yeah
i was a complete garage bander yeah and
then all of a sudden you have headphones
and being like uh can you just do that
again please it's like
this is weird i hate the fact that
people are watching and i can't see them
exactly and what i love about doing um
dtm garageband was that you know if you
hated the take you could re take it like
hundred times yeah
and you know it was completely like um
you know your pace
and if you wanted to perfect it you
could perfect it but when you're in the
studio and there are people directing
you and doing your recording for you
they kind of tell you what to do and
even if you don't like your take you
have to use it or like
there's like a weird pressure where it's
like i could do this a hundred times but
i feel bad for making them wait right
yeah
because because that's paid studio time
isn't it so you feel pressure to have to
kind of take them like optimize the time
you have because
you you've only paid for a certain
amount like so you don't want to do like
another take with like the back of your
head being like oh the direct
[ __ ] right now when i was doing a lot
of voice over in london i i would like
i i had this bad habit right where i
would flub a line instead of like just
letting the
like the line be bad and just like ask
can i redo it i would just say like [ __ ]
at the end of the sentence
so they couldn't use it yeah right
because it would be like that [ __ ] and
then they couldn't use that right but
then
start getting angry like don't do that
because we wanted to use that or we've
got to like splice it together yeah i
had to stop doing that even though i
liked
being able to be like no i don't like
that take i'm going to ruin it let's do
a new one yeah
but uh so that was the huge difference i
think from becoming
amateur to professional um
from from that moment on you are doing
your singing or your work for someone or
you know for
for work so it's an official thing and
it's not just for fun it's not a hobby
anymore
yeah i guess how was the transition
what one of the biggest transition is
obviously getting paid for your work
and because i i feel like you started
off with this being a hobby
how does this how did it feel like
getting your first paycheck doing what
you love
or or how did that feel um
you know like but the weird thing about
music
is that it it always continuously feels
like
a sort of hobby and so right it's
probably different from
another sort of type of work where you
go there every day to the office work
and
and it just doesn't feel like work like
even when i'm doing my
singing career i'm always having fun i
love doing what i love doing
so um it just never feels like work for
me that's the dream isn't it
yeah that is what you love and loving
what you do right yeah i mean because
for me like
i do my hobby for my job i talk about
[ __ ] anime but there are definitely
some
there are definitely some days where i
wake up and it does feel like work
yeah and it's usually like mornings
where i'm like okay i have things to do
but i really don't want to do it because
it's going to feel like work [ __ ] it i'm
not going to work today
the beauty of being self-employed baby
exactly
so so when you made that album how was
that kind of like distributed was it
aimed at like japanese audience was it
aimed at like english audience like what
platforms
i'm just i'm curious about the whole
process and how it was kind of like
aimed
around yeah um in the beginning uh our
platform was based in japan
we were you know releasing stuff um
especially
anime you know is based in japan so
yeah our outlet was sort of to the
japanese audience but
somehow um you know little by little the
the
global community about me and um
i began doing sort of event lives and
things overseas as well like in asia and
america
and germany australia i went to
australia as well so yeah
i'm jealous
that's the only australian in this room
i have to go yeah
are there any australians in the house
[Music]
good day mate
[Laughter]
i don't want to hear your british accent
did you did you do the g'day mate on
stage i did
people take that i had to do it who told
you
no no what i don't know is that like a
thing that you do for like different
countries
that you go to like do you learn how to
say like hello or whatever in like
different countries uh
in different languages i try to but at
the same time like i'm usually
like restricted time wise so i don't
have to have much to talk but
if i had time to talk i would probably
do a lot of hey guys just gonna talk for
15 minutes before i perform
that's okay yeah like kanye west no time
no time to sing sorry
so how many places have you performed
out of curiosity now um
mostly in asia but america australia
singapore malaysia indonesia
germany okay whereabouts in america did
you go san jose california
atlanta georgia anime conventions or
just
oh okay okay and uh new york which is my
home city so how was it live performing
amazing yeah
it was amazing um going just going back
there felt like you know
going home so i i felt that uh
like two years ago when i went back
because i'm from sydney
in australia so like uh we have a
convention in australia called smash
ah yeah like big big anime convention so
like
getting invited there as a guest just
felt so much
better than like any other con
experience i've ever been to because it
was
like going back home and being like look
how much this city has grown
it's so amazing because i went to smash
in 2013 when there was like
2 thousand people three thousand people
something like that and the year i went
there was i think
maybe fifty sixty thousand people that
went to the concert just seeing how much
it grew
wow was like you know what i love my
city
this city is pretty freaking dope one
time you feel patriotic yeah
one time
meanwhile i just see a open field and
i'm like wow that's oh that's that's
that's awesome that's a lot of sheep
right there
yeah you probably feel amazing though if
you were like invited to a con in wales
though right there's like none there's
like no concept
i i would like to get invited to a con
in brighton but
like the uk con scene is just
non-existent
really like it's yeah as you would know
because we have i think one big
convention which which is not even a
convention it's like
mcm and that's more like an expo and
that's like a comic
gaming films and also anime experts
okay were you a convention girl before
you started actually i've never been to
a convention
just by myself so that was a huge
big culture like experience for me it
was crazy well i i
i feel like it's i it would be scary to
go to a convention by yourself
i don't know about your guys's first
convention but uh i mean i didn't go
until i started youtube so
really yeah yeah because i mean well i
mean besides smash in 2013 but i was
already doing youtube back then
right like even then like i had to be
like yo anybody in my area that knows
anything about anime i don't care if
you've only watched like one episode of
dragon ball z you can just go with me
please because like i don't want to go
by myself
because it's like even at a con with
like a couple thousand people
yeah it's just daunting going on your
own because it's like you get there and
it's like okay there's a bunch of people
who probably like the same stuff as i do
yeah but there's a part of me that feels
really weird just going up being like
so you like anime huh like you can't
really do that
i i totally understand what you mean
because i you i don't know how to
properly break the ice yeah right so it
doesn't help in the uk that no one talks
to each other yeah
when someone talks to you like what the
[ __ ] i feel it'd be so much easier in
america because there's already like
this stranger friendliness going on
right like you can just talk to someone
on the street and they'll probably reply
back to you probably if you go to an
anime convention in america
people will people would approach you
sometimes yeah right if you're just
wearing a cool cosplay or
won't work like that in australia no not
in england at all i've never done
cosplay before
have you never no have you i haven't i
haven't well i've done quite a lot
really he kind of done that for a living
in a sense yeah i've done it like once
or twice
i'm not very cute when i say when they
say i do for a living
that's very sarcastically this episode
is sponsored by expressvpn so boys i
have a confession
yeah i know we've been living in japan
at all right but i don't watch anime
on tv here what because i still need it
subbed and that's why i use crunchyroll
to watch my anime
using expressvpn because crunchyroll is
blocked here in japan i actually do that
too
yeah i sometimes do that too i need the
subs man what am i supposed to do
learn japanese no i'm wondering what
shows are you watching
right now i am watching jiu jitsu kaisen
slime season 2
and many more exam as well but the good
thing is expressvpn lets you change your
online location so that you can control
where you want sites to think
you're located just by opening the app
selecting a location tapping one button
to connect and refreshing the page to
access
thousands of new shows and movies just
like that that's crazy that's crazy
choose from almost
100 different countries watch studio
ghibli films on uk netflix watch anime
on japanese netflix watch doctor who on
uk netflix
and see many many more this also works
on any streaming service from hulu
bbc iplayer youtube and many more
you can stream in hd no problem no
buffering or lag and it's compatible
with all your devices phones laptops
media consoles smart tvs
and microwaves it no it doesn't work on
your microwave not only does it let you
change your location it also encrypts
your data and lets you surf the web
safely and anonymously
that is why you should choose expressvpn
over other vpns so go to
trash expressvpn.com to get an extra
three free months for free
that's expressvpn.com trash taste that's
crazy
you sure i i that's what the script says
wow okay well back to the video
all right so if you had to start
cosplaying who would be your first
cosplay actually
like i i have no idea any
recommendations you should do a cosplay
of like
either a batoon character or like an
arpeggio character like like it would be
cool
if you didn't platoon one of the
characters look cool
wasn't there one female character in the
tomb yeah
that's all i remember was like one hair
it was the blonde hair girl right
yeah in a school uniform yeah yeah well
that's what i'm saying like i feel like
arpeggio would be
a lot more like cosplay friendly because
that's it it's actually like
interestingly looks cool
and like that it would be dope if say
hypothetically you
sang the arpeggio opening in in a
cosplay
of an arpeggio character oh my gosh
that's really like that would be better
that would be meta
that's very cheesy it's cheesy but you
know you know
con goes with [ __ ] film over that
well like outside of just like
uh anime that you've sung in like what
are some of your favorite anime
characters that you
would like to cosplay i guess i don't
know but
um like looks aside just just anyone
that you like
ah i don't know i'm putting you on the
spot here i just realized
anime now still lately i haven't been
able to watch much
but i've always like in the past one of
my favorite series i've been like
um full metal alchemist and
my favorite god is no tourist he's
notorious for not having watched it
as he should because he's an amazing
anime
so um you know any anime with really
good music hooks me on and then i start
watching it but i usually
watch sort of like adventure series
where the main character is
like a guy or a boy or not very like
muay muy siri
right right right i feel like well like
it makes sense with formal archives
because the ban
the openings in that are bangers
i haven't seen brotherhood yet but the
first brotherhood opening is [ __ ]
legendary oh yeah and also you know the
asian kung fu generation opening as well
like yeah it's
so much so much good music in that when
i listen to anime opening
songs i can't figure out why i like them
i just like the noise
i'm curious if you have like uh like you
must have
like an ear for it right like what makes
a good anime opening in your opinion i'm
curious
if it's sung by me
um you know i used to listen to anime
openings before i made a w
so what sort of hooked me on was you
know
number one it's really catchy uh number
two
um you know it captures the mood of
the anime very well um and
you know um i don't know but number i
don't
what makes what makes an anime opening i
don't know because i have no clue i
thought maybe you could answer their
questions
i feel though you kind of answered that
like it is all about like
if you just personally like it it sticks
in your head
and if it fits the theme right usually
though you know um
if it's sort of what do you call it like
jose dickie sort of you know um
individual
then unique unique yeah then it sort of
stands out and when something stands out
then like it catches your attention
right yeah because i
remember when i when i was in school and
i watched a load of anime and people
would ask me the question of uh
well what are what are some what are the
music you listen to who are your
favorite artists and i go through like
my ipod or something and it's just all
[ __ ] anime openings
and i'm just like oh there's this really
like underground japanese band called
like
asian kung fu generation you probably
haven't heard of them
yeah but that was the thing though right
like there was some kind of like
level of like superiority in a sense
being like yeah
yes i listen to underground japanese
music you probably never heard yeah but
but now
i feel like everyone listens to anime
openings or anime music because everyone
figures out that it slaps hard so
now the superiority is listening to a
band that's done in anime opening but
listening to all the songs that aren't
in the anime exactly
that are like every other song on the
album it's like you only know the
opening i know the rest of the album
no it's it's like i've i've recently
gotten gotten into like a lot of uh
different artists who
like in in like j-pop and j-rock who
have not been in anime openings or have
not done anime music
but sound like they should have done
anime music and i feel like a lot of
those people
and bands really came up from the
vocaloid community
and i don't know like that's that's why
there's so much i don't know about the
vocaloid community but
everyone seems to have come out of that
community and have this
kind of genre of music that just kind of
appeals to weave i can't
i can't like quantify in words but it's
the kind of music that i just love and i
don't know what that genre is maybe you
titays
yeah i guess it's like yeah i know i
know what you mean though it's like it
even if the genres are completely
different there's just kind of like a
stylistic or like
something about it where it's like that
sounds like it belongs in an anime yeah
like you can very
quickly tell like with uh with you know
japanese music if something is like
made for anime and something's not made
for anime there's just some quality
about it that i can't grasp where it's
like
yeah that you can tell the difference in
that one thing i did realize after
making a w as a sort of anime singer um
was that enemy songs and um
well i don't know how do you say that
regular j-pop or j-rock there is
a distinct difference right and um
you know a lot of people tend to like
faster pace
really like energetic songs and animes
because
you're limited to one minute and 30
seconds
and has to catch your attention so um
usually the ballads are saved for
endings
and the really fast pace which is why i
started singing like bpm 200
right like dying in the studio because
i've never sung
bpm 200 and after all after that all my
songs became like really high-paced
yeah yeah i think i tried playing some
of your songs on osu and my mouse
couldn't keep
up so i mean what does that say it's
just like instant copy i'm like
it's going so fast yes i really don't
recognize i mean like money wise yeah
please do sing my songs at karaoke but i
don't recommend
like singing my songs at karaoke because
of the
sort of level i mean if you're having a
hard time singing them i don't know how
some people
how us yeah right peasant normies are
gonna be able to sing personally would
not sing my songs at karaoke
it's like you know when you get like two
drinks in you're like yeah i think i can
do eminem and then you do it and you're
like i
i didn't remember this many lyrics where
were all these i thought it was just
slim shady standard
it's not just eminem it's like the
really long like four
versus eminem seven minutes long
i thought it alternatively where you
think you you choose a song
and you think you know the lyrics and
you then you realize you only know about
two sentences from the chorus
and then there's just this awkward one
minute where you're just kind of like
humming along to the verse
is it annoying being a singer and then
having to go to karaoke because they
expect you to like kill everything
instead of just you know just
shouting i does i have a secret i sang
my own songs at karaoke
and um you know they have a really
uh weird system where they like the midi
soundtracks
no they have this weird system where
they like to give you a score of how
good you see
i turn that off my own songs
and i got like a sixty percent
cause i was like well like i had someone
out there
exactly i was like wow so it's like when
charlie chaplin
entered like a charlie chaplin and look
like contest they came in third yeah
yeah
that's like the equivalent like like the
points where they
score you are really are very distinct
and
i tend to like um do arrangements and do
weird like stuff with my songs so i
don't sing it exactly like i did at the
studio yeah
so that automatically like
those those games do like the pitch it's
truly off pitch right yeah so it's just
like you could just go oh
and it'll like it'll it'll give you like
power it's just like very basic sing
star kind of yeah
i'm a bad singer so i've never scored
well on any of those kinds of karaoke
games why i turn it off i don't want it
on
i don't know how bad i am at seeing it's
very bad have you ever been in the group
who
hasn't known that you were a singer or
and then you just start singing your own
song
and they're like wait a minute you sound
just like that person singing
sing the song
actually ever since i uh you know made a
debut i haven't been to karaoke because
it became
singing became my career wow it's it's
difficult to
do it for fun now yeah so i mean it's
just work for you and what
it's and when i start singing i
automatically feel like i'm on stage so
i
i think that's a little bit heavy for
the karaoke goers
so i thought we were having fun having a
private concert right here
yeah that's that's a little bit of a
flex right going to a karaoke and
singing your own songs that's
it that's that's a bit of a pleasure
then i usually am the one like just uh
putting everyone's um songs into the
machine yeah
i love doing the tambourine i guess
though it would be such a weird pressure
to go to karaoke with you
you absolutely kill your songs and be
like oh [ __ ] now i got to do sexy back
just the difference yeah
i want to know when you uh started doing
the anime openings
how did that affect the album that was
already out and how like you were i
guess your like level of fame if you
will and how it all
kind of did you see any like results
from doing anime
definitely um i think my fan base sort
of changed
um of course my my original fans stuck
with me
loyally very loyally as i don't know in
japan
exactly which is really an amazing thing
but at the same time like
i started out with my fan base being
mostly girls because um on nico nico
i think a lot of the fan base was very
like female based
right my fan base was female based
but after i made an anime debuts so
batum
um arpeggio that made my sort of
male fan base and that was huge when i
went overseas and did concerts
i was really happy to see that my fan
base my audience
was kind of like hybrid you know like
everyone was there
not just like females yeah exactly and
so
you know and i always have loved rock
and roll so you know i think it's
not necessarily a gender-based um music
genre
so yeah i was really happy to see that
my fan base was growing
um globally and diversity
and so that's why you kind of went
through a similar thing right like you
went from like a primarily female fan
base to
more of a hybrid now right yeah yeah
yeah like was it
was it like similar to you where it's
like you just kind of saw that like if
you didn't have an anime to uh no no
jumpstarters
he just went from more more like one
yeah exactly
so to give you a rough example i just i
basically used to pretend to be a
british butler
isn't that fun how do you pretend to be
a british butler
well you just turn up the british accent
more than usual so you'd go like i
suppose i could talk like this you know
he was he was a actual living anime
avatar for a while yeah yes i didn't
just like show my face much just do
something like that but
i mean anyway that as you can imagine
that kind of thing would attract more of
a female audience than uh
exactly which is why my fan base was
female because i uh didn't show my face
in the beginning and my voice is pretty
low for a female singer
yeah so um a lot of people didn't know
my uh
gender and so they assumed there was a
huge fan base that assumed that i was a
young boy
you know you can imagine the shock when
i did my first concert probably like
what the [ __ ] i wanted a young
boy i'm sure there were audience people
like that
so um but you know after i started
showing my face though
my fan base started to become more
diverse and not just
you know to one genre so how did like
i mean did you did you ever used to have
fan interactions and if so how did that
change when you went from that audience
because i noticed a very distinct change
in how my audience i suppose and behaves
and talks to me
when i went to more mail yeah um
but personally i didn't have much
interaction with my fan until
fans until uh yeah my conventions and my
lives and so
um i don't really have like a comparison
between my nico nico days and my um
debut days but
definitely i love being able to interact
with like my listeners right now
this is amazing i love being able to
hear them hear their voices directly
and so like i have no regrets about like
going open
with my identity do you feel like it
really hits you when you go to a
convention and you
physically see the people that are you
know in front of you that you're
performing in front of
because for us youtubers we see a number
and the number kind of just doesn't mean
anything means means nothing
you don't see a face yeah we don't see a
face and then we try to like even trying
to quantify
in our heads just it doesn't mean
anything until we go to a convention and
we actually see
the amount of people in front of us and
we're like oh these
people all know me jesus christ that's a
lot of insane how it's like
a million views on a youtube video seems
so much smaller than physically seeing a
hundred people in front of you
and it's such a weird dichotomy how that
works and it's like
yeah and it's like you know like we
could be happy with all the views we get
on all the videos but at the end of the
day
it doesn't really you can't see anything
right it doesn't mean it doesn't really
mean anything i mean it means something
but it doesn't mean
as much as it should it's not as weird
yeah exactly exactly
before you debuted had you ever like
performed on a big stage before or
anything like that no my first
ever concert in my entire life was in
front of 2000 people
wow a solo concert god and so when the
when the curtain went up i almost like
yeah
i was like like
you know like i just went up two octaves
right there
so like i almost died on stage what's
the biggest crowd you've ever performed
in front of
um it was at an event and it's
and that so that was uh probably like
so ten thousand somewhat number of
people
wow but when it becomes that sort of
number
you can't see the faces so it's like a
sea of lights and like pen lights
so it you don't become nervous anymore
it's just like
when it's it's more nerve-wracking when
you're in a small venue
and you see every single face and
they're all looking at you
it's the eye contact that really that
really gets you high five fine
because we don't have that experience i
mean like what's the biggest amount of
people
saying x right ax i think i mean
i hosted in front of like three yeah two
or three thousand people two thousand
and that right i was [ __ ] my pants
yeah i hate it when you make eye contact
with yourself like two seconds and
you're like
do you reckon they noticed they 100
percent notice that was that weird that
was weird
can you imagine doing a panel in front
of 10 000 people i would like to not
yeah i would like to not either i gotta
ask do you ever get
is it is like do you ever get nervous
before going on stage do you ever get
used to that
um i'm not a huge person like a nervous
person so i'm usually
pretty like excited to go on stage right
and i'm like i'm gonna have
fun this is my home you know yeah
so i i really don't get nervous but when
i do get nervous though um
you know uh it doesn't it's every time i
do get a little bit nervous
yeah i i love being on stage because i i
feel for me it's it's
i don't know if it's nerves but i just i
just it's the waiting that kills me i
just want to get on stage whenever
whenever i have like a panel scheduled
or whatever and a lot of people i just
feel like once i get on stage i'm gonna
be fine but before that i'm just
i'm just restless it's like it's like
you're backstage and you just hear the
murmur of the crowd right that's when
it's the most nervous but the moment i
start like going up the stairs
it's just it's just gone that's exactly
true like i hate the waiting of it the
waiting is the most nerve-wracking point
once you're on stage then you just gotta
do what you gotta do so
yeah did you discover like the first
time you're on stage was it like a
aha moment this is i love this oh i
thought yeah
this is definitely where you know i want
to be i'm
i'm so grateful to have this chance to
actually do what i love doing
and i don't know it's just i'm so
this is perfect you know for me because
i i assume it's kind of like a trial by
fire because
you said you had no stage experience
before because like i can only imagine
some other artists who just kind of
didn't take to the stage as well
would uh would have would have fallen
flat i went on stage
in japan for a video recently where i
like did like a visual k
video and um it was awful i hated it
because it was like it was like 30
people so it's very intimate
right and like yeah because it also
covered no one was allowed to like move
everyone just had to stand yeah which
makes it even worse because i wasn't
doing anything
right i was just head banging but
anytime i stopped and made even like
a millisecond of eye contact with
someone and they were just like
i was like oh my god i'm awful i'm
terrible i'm ruining the whole thing
um yeah needs to say i i was i was uh
not happy about it
it's like it's like doing a performance
in front of your family right and they
just like being here yeah
but at least your family you know your
family's gonna have your back no matter
what
i figured out when i have to go on stage
and do something to actually be good at
it
that's when i get nervous because i'm
like people have expectations
like it's okay to be bad at it and like
that's the whole joke uh
yeah i like that because it's like all
right i'm just gonna be a clown that's
what they carry
that's what i guess that's like the the
benefit of like you know doing a panel
for us
most if not all the people who are
attending it know us
enough that even if we [ __ ] up slightly
they'll be like
that's just him you know i have no
talent so what am i going to do on stage
but i find i i've only really you know
my career
took off in japan right yeah i'm not an
american-based singer but at the same
time i grew up in america
and i've been going to concerts in
america and i did realize after my debut
that the japanese sort of entertainment
industry is completely
different from the american 100 100
different and
the sort of um expectations in japan are
very high
you have to be perfect you know a lot of
people are you know
require perfection as part of the job so
um that is always very nerve-wracking to
be able to have to
sort of think oh you know i have to
perform perfectly on stage but that's
impossible
i feel like it's even like that when
you're ordering a drink at starbucks
here they think they asked
oh my god they're gonna hate me i didn't
put the little straw in and it's like no
no it's okay
i feel so bad they're freaking out but i
mean how how
is the difference between performing in
japan and say america
you know like in america i feel that
when i go on stage it's
it's like a live it's really like a live
thing it's a live experience you're with
your fans you don't
it's nothing is planned you know your
set list is planned but everything else
is like
uh you know you've got a lot more
freedom yeah it's freedom it's it's up
to luck
yeah but in japan i think even the fans
are
very loyal in the sense that they really
want you to do your best and they're
always like hoping to do well
[Music]
you know but you know so it's it's the
expectations are completely different i
do love performing independence as much
as i do
love performing overseas as well but at
the same time it's just a different
experience right
yeah i feel that um japan is more based
on like you know
just doing things absolutely to the best
as you can
always being you know just perfect has
anything bad ever happened on stage or
something that you didn't predict
that you kind of just had to deal with
on the spot um
luckily i haven't had huge misses but
i'm always like the fear of miss messing
up is like
here so like it's healthy though yeah
that's
you got to have that right if you're too
complacent yeah like you won't you won't
do like your butt it does appear
as nightmares in my dreams
you wake up in a cold sweat and you're
like oh what if i [ __ ] up on stage
i don't know how many times i've had
nightmares where i've
completely like messed up my lyrics
or like i i don't even know my own songs
on stage or like i'm like what am i
doing on stage i don't even know what to
sing i don't know
i i've my lyrics are completely washed
out
so i think um like somewhere in my head
i'm always
like that's the fear of mine yeah
messing up on stage
so like how is i suppose how has covid
kind of
affected your schedule what'd you like
what what's the day in the life of nano
what what you
what do you do now that you know you
can't go on stage
but like i said though um as a as like a
regular
like nano not like a musician you know
i'm a very stay-at-home person
yeah this is very like not not too
different from my very comfortable yeah
it's not too different from
your comfort zone but last year in 2020
i had a
a lot of um overseas events planned a
lot of my own tour was actually
cancelled last
year due to covid's so um in the music
industry though kovid has really taken
its toll
yeah yeah um and that's not just me for
all the musicians and
entertainment entertainers out there so
we're we're really struggling in that
sense to be able to find new ways to
um reach out to the audience and to give
back to the audience
even without being able to directly you
know interact with them
so but that's i think a good sort of
start for us yeah because i i assume
that being at home have you had more
time to work on new music
or yeah we've been doing a lot of
creating at home so we're
we're using we're trying to use our at
home time wisely we're
doing we've you know been creating music
and getting ready for when the time
comes when we're able to
do lives again it's gonna be a hell of a
comeback yeah
hopefully honestly like once like covert
is gone like the amount of concerts that
are just gonna like
pop up out of nowhere everyone's like i
don't have time to go to all these
concerts right yeah i'm just
there's gonna be so many events that i
want to go to when things start opening
up again i'm just gonna
my schedule's gonna be so packed but
with non-work related yeah
yeah i wanna go to the cinema you can't
even get popcorn it's so sad i know
they're like you can't you can go to the
cinema all right and you can sit next to
other people now but
that the the reason it used to be to
socially distance with one seat yeah
sit next to each other but the drawback
is you're not allowed to have popcorn oh
no then i'm not going
to i never i never buy i never buy
popcorn yeah it's part of the theater
i i hate it because like it's because
like as you saw earlier i go to the
toilet all the free
yeah me too so like when i eat popcorn i
get thirsty
so i have to drink but then i have to go
to the toilet and i'm going to miss some
of the film so i almost
i've i've learned my lesson now like i
have the bladder of a five-year-old boy
so i i'm just gonna order a little trade
secret
so when we record trash taste we have to
take a break every 30 minutes to reset
the cameras
and me and joey go to the toilet
basically every time
every time during the breaks because we
have a very small bladder
embarrassing that's that's why i know
now it's just like i'm just not gonna
get popcorn anymore i love it like if if
i'm with someone and they have a bucket
of popcorn
yeah i'm taking that [ __ ] popcorn's the
one food that i don't buy for myself but
when someone offers me yeah
i never say no i'm just taking it i'm
saying i'll offer you my pocket
i'm eating all of that wow rude should
we take a break every i do actually need
the toilet
this episode is sponsored by customcast
an app available on ios and android
devices that let you achieve your dreams
of becoming
a virtual uh cute anime girls
not what i was about to say but yes the
custom cast app lets you create your
own customizable virtual avatar in the
free basic version you can create your
own high quality 3d avatar in just a few
minutes
you don't even need a phone number or a
social media account to register hello
gentlemen
arda ara you can customize your avatar
with many different hairstyles
clothes backgrounds body sizes etc you
can always choose to be a kawaii anime
girl like me and god
or you can try and make your character
look like you but
cooler like me i can't get over how cute
you look joey i know right you kind of
look like an
older sister god and we're not related
by blood what the
get out of here anyways if you feel like
going all out you can also make in-app
purchases to unlock tons of unique
features
and if you want to use your avatar to
stream all you have to do is select the
stream button on home
and you're all set to make your vtuber
debut your face will be detected by the
virtual camera on your device and your
virtual character will move based on
your facial expressions and movements
such as tilting or turning your head you
too can become the waifu
or husbando of your dreams since both
girl and boy avatars can be created so
check the links in the description below
to give it a download
and now i'm sad i'm gonna have to go
back to my real persona for the rest of
the show thank you for sponsoring
this episode custom cast now back to the
episode so like you talked before about
you know the pressure of performing in
japan because they expect perfection and
we've talked before
on his podcast by like idol culture in
japan and how
they kind of expect perfection not only
like on the stage but
off the stage as well yeah you really
get put on a pedestal here
here it seems like what's it like in
your position do you feel like you
you have the pressure to be like perfect
in every aspect of your life
or do you just not give a [ __ ] um
well during for example like the
concerts themselves are completely
different like i said um
japanese audiences tend to uh sort of
enjoy
the emcee talking sections a lot and so
they like to
hear about like your private life and
what you're doing
and like they like to hear you talk but
then they uh for example the
overseas audience they just want to like
have to do the music playing the anime
opening
yeah exactly so you know i end up not
talking much on stage when i go overseas
but um
yeah i think in the japanese industry
though they they have like
they have exactly image of what kind of
concert they want to do and then you do
that exact kind of concert
and then also the fans have like a very
they like to in
like make you a character right yeah
kind of character sort of thing
so um it was it was kind of interesting
though like
i became a nano character in the
beginning and um
i tried to sort of live up to that
expectation but then i realized that you
know it's kind of impossible
so little by little like i'm becoming a
lot more freedom
yeah right now i'm just you know me but
have you ever had any uncomfortable
situations arise from you know trying to
be more yourself and the the fans
wanting this perfect image of you
um well i did sort of
think about like uh is this what sort of
character nano would do or say or not
you know that kind of thing weird
because you aren't mad
what would the fans think that i would
do i should do that
what is like the main difference between
the character nano and like
you as just nana it was really
sort of um distinct because i didn't
show my face in the beginning
right so anything that sort of
showed like a personality not on stage i
i did but i mean photos
so i never showed my face in photos and
stuff and so
anything that sort of showed a
characteristic of myself
human side of nano so so so if i'm
understanding this correctly they
created a character not like did they
make a law around it or was it just how
they perceived
the way you would act off camera
well it was kind of like my artist image
as well so
my director also wanted to go in a
direction where i was
you know not too open i was more
mysterious yeah yeah and who's nano
you know is are they a boy or a girl
japanese audiences love
that [ __ ] they love like the mysterious
because you can then apply
you know based off the music yeah yeah
yeah i think oh i think they're like
this and they must be like this yeah
but actually it did help me focus on my
music more yeah
because i didn't have to um think about
you know what i looked like
what you know my image was like i could
just focus on my music
and not you know focus on the other
aspects of the visual aspects yeah
because i feel like a lot of people
forget that in the music industry
sometimes a lot of
like image is just as important as the
music as well so being able to focus on
the music
i feel is a big advantage because you
can that just means you can just
focus on what you're really passionate
about
yeah but it's always like you know they
always think that you know people on
like uh
x factor and american idol american idol
because they're too humanized
to us and that we see them way too
similar to ourselves
they don't almost they don't work very
well as pop stars because they're not
larger than life characters yeah so i
feel like in almost some aspects you'll
kind of have to like not tell everyone
about everything about yourself because
they're going to think like oh well
i know everything about nana she's like
a normal i'm everyday person but if
you're like
oh my god mysterious person who's
amazing at music it's like yeah perhaps
now that i'm completely myself
the facade is gone we are breaking the
fourth war now
yeah like i i saw like it's very similar
to like um
i read like this article on uh how the
reason why daft punk
uh hides their faces now yeah it's
because like yeah it's exactly the same
thing it's like they just want to like
completely focus on the music they want
to like
basically cut off the connection between
the person making the music and the
actual music so
yeah now the two members of darpan they
can do whatever the [ __ ] they want in
their personal life
like no one can say anything otherwise
right so they could be at their own
concert
in the crowd and no one would actually
know but that was so convenient because
i could go anywhere and do anything
without people
realizing who i was right right so i
could you know go to the convenience
store in pajamas and be like whoo-hoo
[Laughter]
or like recognized in japan absolutely
no i haven't really wow
what if you have but they just didn't
come to you yeah
in her pajamas at a family mart was
there tmz
that does that now is there like a
japanese tmz
or i don't know it's just just seeing
like the youtube channel
what's the youtuber like youtuber tmz oh
no i have seen that pretty creepy they
like follow like the thought
filter right something like that
something like that like the 13 14
tick tock stars yeah some questions it's
like what do you think
it's mostly it's mostly in la right yeah
it's just
that way yeah because i i see some of
those you know tmd youtubers now and i
i get this image that just la youtubers
live on a different
planet la just works differently from
the rest of the world i'm pretty sure
but i spent so much time um you know not
having
an identity yeah so for like years
and years i spend doing music just you
know without an identity so
now that i do have an identity and i'm
more free now
sometimes i don't know who i am
sometimes i'm like you know lost at that
point but um oh this is getting pretty
deep
no i i i totally get it though it's like
you know it is a very uncomfortable
thing where you're like
am i the character that people think i
am or what is because
this is stressful because i i've i've
experienced like something similar doing
youtube where
i don't know if my personal because my
personality has shifted in like the 10
years i've done youtube but
have i shifted because i've done youtube
or have i
you know have i shifted because of my
own personal reasons i don't know
the way i try and like tell people at
least i think i tell myself this to like
this is right right
like like i i think i present like an
image of myself
that is like me on my best days right
it's you know because obviously you know
you get sad
you you get those days you don't want to
do anything and you're literally you're
sure you're here yeah yeah
yeah not fun to be around obviously i'm
not going to show that but then it's
like am i lying by not showing that like
i don't know i hate exactly
it's so comfortable because i i feel
like that when there's a camera i feel
like i have to be in like the good mode
the entertaining mode where sometimes
you know you just don't feel like
being entertaining or talking um i just
gotta like take the smile pill right
[Music]
i'm on camera now hey yeah it's it's
tough
like and i feel like you know i i can
completely see why
like you know especially on the youtuber
side right like why there is kind of
been this like kind of
i've almost seen as like a growing thing
of faceless youtubers
just because i think people are starting
to realize the kind of
not risk per se but you know the the
demerits to like showing your face and
showing your
self honesty it's way more pressure and
i've noticed that since because i
i started off with most people not
knowing much about me
and then trash taste started and now i'm
on camera every week and it's something
that i just haven't been used to
at all i just can't be bothered going
through all the effort of like hiding my
identity but you know
like i said earlier though i think the
japanese industry the entertainment
industry used to be very sort of strict
and they expected you to sort of portray
an artist's image yeah like idols
like it was a it would be a huge scandal
right if they were dating something yeah
but um thanks to youtube and like this
recent
sort of generation um you know a lot of
musicians
and uh entertainers are starting to
become youtubers
i think that's a huge plus because
they're realizing that they can be
themselves more and still work be human
yeah and be human and
people are actually looking for that now
yeah and so this is a huge
uh big sort of uh you know plus for the
entertainment industry and i think it's
a good change for us
and i feel it's a chance for us to be
more of ourselves
and to really um put out you know our
own messages
into our work did you have any control
over your own like
artist image or was that beginning um
this is my first time actually talking
about this and i would love to talk
about it
okay exclusive let's go let's go no but
everything
in the beginning of my uh career because
i was completely
amateur like usually rock artists
start doing their stuff before their
debut like they do
small lives venues yeah tours they have
a fan base
but for me like day one that my fans
uh you know made a w with me was my day
one as well
right and i didn't do lives before that
i didn't have media coverage anything
out there so it was just nico nico
and so um i needed
aid i needed direction yeah and so
my director and made sort of this image
of who
what kind of artist i should be and i
tried to sort of
um be that right that it could
so in the beginning though um everything
was completely like
you know um decided for you yes decided
for me
and i didn't even know what i wanted yet
as a musician yeah so
i couldn't say you know hey i want to do
this i wanted i just wanted to sing
yeah right right that's how it normally
is artists just kind of
a lot of thing i noticed about artists
is that they just want to focus on the
yard and they have
no idea about how to market themselves
or branding
helped me to have the direction right
and to be told like you know
um everything other than the singing
part to do how to do this how to do that
they taught me about the entertainment
industry they taught me how to do lives
they taught me how to take artist
photographs you know
everything god i wish i knew that yeah
right we just kind of had to like
learn on the job and take an array of
the most
awkward photos that have ever been taken
it was so sad because i didn't show my
face but i had to take artist
photographs
i was always wearing a hood right yeah
so i was like
standing in front of the camera wearing
a hood and not showing my face
and i was like you know this could be
anyone else anyone else
yeah a mannequin and no one would notice
yeah right does it have to be me
you know that kind of thing even in my
promotion videos i didn't show my face
and so my
neck was always like this and by the end
of the video i'd be like oh my neck
my neck so you know that that happened
behind the cameras and there were a lot
of things that were difficult in the
beginning
right but now that i think about it it
was really funny
it was it was really funny and fun and
it helped me learn about a lot
of things did you have to do you ever
have to that point where you had to like
work on your signature or did you have a
good looking signature to begin with
when you signed things
um i just used i still use to this day
uh just a regular like
cursive signature i'm so jealous i
literally just do like four circles and
i'm like
bam i would love to have a cool looking
signature but i don't know how to do it
because i never
i think joey out of all of us has the
coolest looking signature
which is hilarious because i came up
with that
signature my signature um do we have
like a thing
because like i came up with my signature
i think in like it was the first con i
ever went it was
basically the first time i ever had to
sign something like someone came up to
me and was like
and you made it up man i love your work
can you can you sign something and i'm
like
what who who the [ __ ] wants a signature
from me you made that up on the spot
i made that up on the spot and i was
like you know what good enough this is
because this is going to be my signature
for the rest of my life while joey's
doing his thing jump because
i remember the first time i got asked to
do my signature i look like a deer in
i look like a lost deer in headlights
look at that that's
that's that's my signature that looks
cool that looks like a proper artist's
signature i could sell that on yahoo
yeah i literally i was like okay what is
like a distinct thing
about a signature lots of like
unnecessarily long lines lots of like
over to the point where it needs to be
illegible basically let me show you how
it's done
so show me your signature uh my mine's
mine's mine i think it's in between and
i was like okay i can't just like write
the anime man
i can see that you probably came up with
that in in which is
great that seems like
listen you think when picasso was in the
museum you had to put up with this [ __ ]
listen let me explain all right
you have the c the d and then i just do
whatever it's always like i do the c and
d and i give up sorry this is this is
like
you know signature okay i'll do it this
is like when the kid brings back a
drawing
as well yeah this is like when the kid
brings like a drawing to their parents
when they're like three or something and
their parents have to act impressed
like oh you did this oh it looks so good
it's not even that
in japan they'll be like oh full
signature please and i'm like oh of
course of course then i just do that
they're like they look at me like what
was that that wasn't full signature
that's mine it's not as good as joey's
but that's pretty close
it's okay
yeah that clearly says gear i looked at
this and i'm like who's dan
honestly i this this is cleaned up a lot
because i have a unique one every time
this is [ __ ]
you can why would i want this ever i
thought
no i'm actually looking for a new
signature
right so you guys can think of one for
me
which kind of style do you like the most
one one hint i need is a lot of like
a lot of squiggles i like the squiggles
a lot of pointless lines right yeah
model calls higher iq yeah so yeah but
my name is pretty uh
difficult i mean just go as cursive as
you can you're like this is
put on put on the top hat and the
monocle you know i go for the doctor
i kind of like this yeah right see yeah
i kind of like like
see dan it's mine
so maybe i'll just like get rid of the
oh yeah right
just go cnn
have you guys ever had a fan ask you to
redo a signature
oh yeah i have because i i've had that
before
and that's why because my signature
looks a lot better than they used to
because before it used to
look something like this and i i
remember i put i put this
on like on like a guy's shirt because he
wanted me to sign a shirt
and he dead ass looks at that and like
he was like
can you do that again please i can't
read that i got a good one for you can i
have that
all right so i was at a bar with a
friend in the middle of nowhere in japan
and for some reason he thought it'd be
entertaining to tell the the person at
the bar i was a youtuber i
normally don't want to do that i hate it
when they do because it's just it's just
like you're not going to get it if i
show you and you you're not you're only
going to be impressed by the numbers and
not what it actually is right so it's
like don't don't do it so he does it
anyway so i'm like quite drunk and
they're like can you please
for some reason they brought out a
cheeky [ __ ] like 2 a.m and i'm already
i'm already pretty i'm
pretty drunk so they hand it to me and
i'm i'm trying my best to
do this yeah right so all i do in the
end is just this
i do this and they were like whoa and
i'm like looking at my friend i'm like i
can't believe they're taking that and
they put they hung it up on the wall
in front of me and i doubt it's still
there they must have taken that down so
well it's like the signature that we did
at army army right
like a like a figurine store yeah
one of the biggest ones and at one part
of this store they have
this just this massive line of like
maybe like 50 skishis from like
artists and like figurines like
sculptors and stuff like that like
proper manga cause proper mangas and
stuff like that
we did a video there and they were like
hey can you sign a skish for us because
you filmed here
and i didn't take into account i didn't
actually think
that we're going to hang it up next to
all these things which is worth nothing
yeah yeah yeah so we were just like
[ __ ] let's let's just do it like
they're probably
they're probably just saying this to be
nice let's just do it turns out i went
back like a week later
it's up there on the wall next to these
incredible looking squishies
and it just looks like absolute dog [ __ ]
like [ __ ] we should have uh the macaroni
art next like the banks yeah yeah
it's pretty it's pretty appalling i was
like [ __ ] it was the first time ever i
was like [ __ ]
i wish they'd just take that down i
don't want this clown it's like it's
like that horse meme where you have like
a really professionally drawn horse
and then the last third is just like a
kid's drawing that was that that's that
that's our drawing in army army but uh
every time someone goes there now they
take a picture and tag us and they
tweeted at us and we're like please
don't run
just the shame just gets more everything
like japanese artists have such
amazing um signatures and they're all
good at
drawing and so i've always felt like
that's a huge like
complex for me yeah why are why is
everyone so good at like autographs yeah
but a signature i think
they're a class that's why i was
genuinely curious do you guys practice
this [ __ ] because i had to make mine up
on the spot that's why mine looks odd
complete
um like just practiced or like i'm still
trying to figure that out
yeah because i feel like when we all
like first had to do signatures right
like it kind of came out of the blue
like you weren't expecting it i feel
like a signature shouldn't be a burden
and when i ask a japanese person to do a
signature it's like
give me 15 minutes and a red bull and
i'll i'll be done no no no
you can just do like some swiggles i
don't care slap it i don't know what
just
i feel bad when they're drawing
something really delicate i'm like this
is just gonna like
be in like my wall somewhere i think the
highest pressure for me is signing a
shikishi
because a shikishi there's a lot of
white space moshi
and there's only so many ways i can make
it look good so like it's
when i have to draw my signature big
it's like it's like enlarging
uh 100 by 100 pixel image you know it's
it's like minecraft quality that we're
talking about it's like 360 youtube
and it just looks bad because we're so
used to doing like the corner of an
anime poster so that it doesn't go over
it right
yeah i i you know ever since i made a w
um in japan like
i've had to uh have you know shikishi
signatures often
and i wanted one advice from me is how
to fill it up is just draw
a lot of stars
that's why my is always from stars
because i don't know what to do with the
whites
yeah but that's the problem right is
that like we have three people who just
cannot draw to save their life yeah so
it's just like
same here do i like draw an anime
character but i don't want to get like
deviant quality like anime character
next to my signature so it's like
what do i so that's why like at least
with my signature my one saving grace
was just like the cat face
just been like i have to add something
to this to make it unique and
one thing i've always found with like
japanese artists or like just
voice actors or whoever is that they
always have like their mark
of like identity i'm just like what's it
for me i'll just put a [ __ ] cat
i think the reason like japanese artists
and and
um entertainers like have sort of
artwork with their signatures is
because they have to sign sushi and they
have to fill up the white space yeah
yeah
yeah exactly yeah basically just put a
cat face or make up an emoji apparently
yeah
or stars or just lots of something lots
of stars this is a problem that
99 of viewers will have zero
relationship with
really relatable time yeah
so you grew up in the us your whole life
exactly
when did you come to japan for the first
time um i i've been coming back to japan
um like pretty much every year when i
was little parents
just to go to my um grandparents house
and stuff
and then i went to uh i came to japan
in middle school um and i experienced
japanese school education for the first
time in my life how was that going from
american school
it was completely hope for me because um
even though i can speak
regular sort of everyday japanese like
read or write um up to par
am i allowed to ask this but why were
you going to school in japan like what
was there a reason
that's the music thing oh okay
oh musician in japan so i came to japan
to do music
and i still had to go to school so i
went to school but i went to regular
school which was a huge mistake and i
didn't go to international school you
know that kind of thing
so how was that why why was it a mistake
i'm curious
um it's just that i couldn't keep up
with any of the education
and i was a complete loner so i didn't
have any friends i was gonna ask is it
hard to make friends when you're like a
transfer student i think it's impossible
to make friends
that's such a lie would have you believe
that the transfer students
they're like everyone wants everyone
wants to know the transfer student why
would you lie to me anime
i think there's like there's that one
scene where it's like a transfer student
from overseas who's like oh they can
speak english and then
during the break they're [ __ ] all
over that transfer student right like
did that happen to you at all
um big surprise here and i and i'm gonna
give you a huge
uh sort of reality check but as an anime
singer
anime is not exactly real
no i respect your opinion i do
but i'm gonna leave in my reality
i mean you didn't sit in like the far
corner of the classroom next to the
window
well actually you know since i came to
japan and then i
started um the school at a very
weird time in the sort of year right i
was like in the corner
and so i couldn't make friends and i
couldn't keep up with the studies and
i everything like the culture was
completely right right yeah it's quite
different for america yeah i guess for
you as well it's like doubly a pressure
right because you're full japanese
everyone expects me to be japanese right
you know if i looked sort of american
probably people would be like you know
nihongo daijoubu but no
people would be like completely normal
you know they expect me to
understand completely everything so that
was huge
stress for me mentally did you how good
was your japanese when you moved here
um i could speak it but reading and
writing was
completely so japanese is technically
your second language yes it's
technically my second language and i
didn't like
actually officially study japanese in
america right okay
so and so you were in japanese school
until
high school then like uh for less than
two years i think
because you're like thank god good girl
gave up and then i went back to the
states and then i finished school there
and then after i finished school i came
to japan
and started my career so okay what is
the japanese education system like
compared to
the us because i i've thought about like
you know if because i was also you know
i was raised in the uk that was where my
education system is
i can't imagine having an education in
asia because that
the culture of the asian education
system just seems like
a lot of pressure yeah and that's
something that i'm not a fan of at all
um i think you know in japan um
i'd i've only been as a student for two
less than two years i can't say i know
everything but at the same time i think
they're very like
like studying based like everything is
about studying studying studying and
it's very difficult
um to be a loner in school in japan like
it's you have to have your sort of niche
and you have to have your place and you
have to friends in order to really
um feel like so
so who are like the cool kids in
japanese schools who are like the
popular kids because in like when i was
growing up it would be like the people
who are good at sports or like the jocks
and stuff like that who is like who are
like the prop what makes you popular in
japanese schools i've always
wondered about i think it is different
in japan like um it doesn't necessarily
mean
like uh you have to be like the most
fashionable or anything but
in japan it's more if you're outgoing
and you're also smart right
educationally
yeah that's what i think anime got right
yeah i noticed there's a big difference
because
when i was growing up in the uk if you
did willing test that's like a that's
like
that's like a black mark you're like
whoa you studied for an exam
look at this [ __ ] nerd whereas in
japan it's like whoa you studied oh my
god you're awesome
you know that kind of thing is different
yeah um like if you're an all-rounder if
you're good at a lot of different things
then
you're pretty much you know the image of
perfection yeah
just go to every you're just good at
everything japan loves perfection yeah
yeah
i think they sort of exert perfection in
the enemy as well like the
animes uh they sort of um depict
perfection in animation yeah yeah i
don't know if
you don't have to answer this question
if you don't want to but did you ever
have like any negative experiences like
bullying because you were
like foreign or um there wasn't exactly
like direct bullying but
people didn't know how to interact with
me because they
because it wasn't international school
and they weren't exposed to foreign
people they at the time though now of
course there are a lot of foreigners in
japan but at the time there were like if
there was a foreigner walking around in
shibuya people would be like
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's still like
that in some cases
didn't have an immune system for like
english and
you know just the foreign that i came
from the us and that i was an
outsider people were like i don't know
how to interact with them
do they know the same language they
didn't really know how to interact with
me
so uh even though i was really outgoing
and a lot i've been a
people lover um now no one really wanted
to
you know sort of interact with me like
directly yeah they were very shy
yeah is very shy so yeah um that was
one of the biggest stresses yeah i
definitely noticed that especially
recently i feel even just like looking
like you know
going out into the town and stuff like
that you do see like
yeah because like when we were in school
like i never went to a japanese school
either
because i just didn't really want to i
heard terrible things about
it um but you know back then it was like
yeah if you're
if you look any different at all
because it's such a collectivist society
you're just not gonna fit in like no
matter how hard you trust i'm like i'm
not even gonna bother with that [ __ ]
but like nowadays like you know the
other day i saw like
a bunch of high school girls in uniform
and
among like the three or four japanese
girls there was like one girl who was
just like
clearly like african-american like black
yeah so it's like full-on and i was and
they were like just
hanging out with her like it was nothing
i'm in my head i was just like hell yeah
finally finally like kids actually like
are starting to understand in japan i'm
like you guys took your [ __ ] time
yeah so if i came to japan
now as a teenager and went to school i'd
probably have a
much better time yeah experience yeah
definitely you know
yeah this video is sponsored by mac
weldon mac weldon is a premium men's
essentials brand that believes in smart
designs and high quality fabrics
and offers a one-stop shop for men's
basics
hell yeah they do after taking a brief
hiatus from outdoor activities and
workout routines it's time to get back
to the grind with new spring essentials
from mac weldon with body mapping
technology
and fabric mesh zones what what
are those well let me tell you gone
mackweldon stealth boxer briefs
uh i do actually own them they are just
in the wash because
those are not the styles joe you would
know the staffs if you actually worked
out as hard as i do because they are so
goddamn comfortable they don't smell
they're amazing they're perfect for
everyday wear or to be layered
underneath
workout gear like this smelly bastard
and for the sweatpants you can wear
outside without feeling like you're
wearing sweatpants at
all check out mac weldon's new ace line
socks shirt hoodies underwear polos or
active shorts magwell and promises
comfort and a consistent
fit and it also looks great and feels
great from working out going out going
to work or on a date magwelton is for
everyday life with a wide range of
customized fabrics that can keep up with
you no matter what your day
looks like and with the weld and blue
totally free loyalty program
level one gets you free shipping for
life
damn that is insane that's a long ass
time and once you reach level two by
spending 200
you get 20 off every order for the next
year and don't forget about the mac
weldon guaranteed
they want you to be comfortable for you
so you know what if you don't like your
first pair of underwear you can keep
them
and they'll still refund you just fine
so for 20 off your first order visit
macweldon.com
trash taste and into the promo code
trash taste that's mackweldon.com
trash taste promo code trash taste for
20 off mack weldon reinventing men's
basics back to the episode
because i feel like it's extra pressure
as well because i
i i kind of relate to that where like i
i feel like if you're like
american or something or you know
something that you know your
your blood isn't from japan um it would
be a lot more exotic
but because you're 100 japanese
coming back to japan you feel like a
foreigner in your own home sometimes
because i felt like i felt like that
when i went back to thailand
right because you know every people like
foreigners in thailand
but for me i'm i feel like i'm a
foreigner in thailand but it's kind of
like a disappointment because
i'm 100 thai but so they expect me to be
fully tired fully fluent and fully
understanding of the culture and
everything but
and when they see that i'm not they're
just like ah okay so
you're not one of us but you're also not
cool for being a foreigner either
like double yeah i i don't get the
advantage of it being either thing this
time would never wear a turtle now i can
completely relate because i grew up in
america but i
i lived on the west coast um for
most of my life and so there were very
few asian people
and at the time though um the japanese
boom
wasn't existent yet yeah so no one
really liked japan yet
everyone was like the asian people were
all one category
yeah yeah you're chinese you're japanese
you're the same thing yeah
and so i felt very like uh
sort of you know left out in the
community i didn't know my identity
there
and so then i came to japan and then i
experienced the same thing where i
didn't have an identity
i wasn't completely japanese i wasn't
completely american well we're still
not um used to having you know foreign
people
in japan yet and so my timing is just
completely off my entire life
because like i mean when i was growing
up in school like i was i swear the only
guy was interested in like any asian
culture and it felt really weird because
like and no one gave a [ __ ] everyone
cared about like
the football that was on yeah cool i
mean but like now it's almost like you
know there's almost a
like a fetishization of like japanese
culture exactly i love japanese yeah so
if i if i grew up in the states
during now i'd be like
i feel like i was growing i grew up in
the wrong era because like kids
kids now find anime did you say that no
because like kids now find anime cool
and [ __ ] and i'm just like bruh
where where were all these kids when i
was like secretly watching anime yeah
we were growing up you get bullied for
watching dragon ball z but now you get
bullied for only watching dragon ball z
wow you only watch dragon ball talk
about this for another two hours
like we can make another youtube video
just for this
topic this is an important topic yeah
honestly because it's like
because i felt that way too like in
australia because i was the only kid
with
any kind of asian blood in him like i
don't look asian
but when you're in a school that is 99.9
white even that one percent of asian
look
sticks out like crazy yeah so and then
you know i have the exact same thing
over here like i don't look japanese at
all so when people [ __ ] you know when i
would say konnichiwa they're [ __ ]
nihongo jozu means
that i'm like it's not hard to say
konnichiwa bro like i can say so much
more
but you're i can say so much more but
you don't even give me the opportunity
to give that to you yeah so it was like
what the [ __ ] do i do yeah it's funny
how times have changed because
i remember talking to my cousin uh who
so who has a son who's going to school
now and he's really into sports he's
like he's like a super jock basically
it's kind of like the opportunity okay
kind of kind of like the opposite of me
a giga jock basically but i remember she
was telling me about
how he got bullied in school right
because he didn't jog
no no yeah for being a joke because he
didn't play fortnite
so this so that's so funny
my mom was telling me the same thing so
my yeah am i younger yeah yeah yeah so
my younger nephew he got bullied for not
playing fortnite so
one day he decides to play fortnite and
then he still got bullied because he had
the default skin
yeah my mom works in a primary school
like kids for like i don't know age of 2
6 and 12. she was telling me that these
the kids were getting bullied because
they didn't have any skins and fortnite
as well
when i was that age it was always the
kid who was the fastest yeah he was like
the coolest
yeah yeah yeah but when i actually
became the fastest kid it wasn't cool
anymore and i was like what the [ __ ]
and then you know i was always good at
video games because i got bullied for
playing video games but now i would
have been like i've been so cool in
school
we all go through that right yeah yeah
yeah yeah
chasing you know the the trend trying to
be no no no
we were ahead of the generation yeah
yeah you were you were so fast that you
out
you outran yeah i quickly i quickly
realized i'm like [ __ ] everyone else i
i like what i like yeah i'm gonna do
what i want we set the trends now
we do trends we the trend now
[Laughter]
yeah i'm curious uh cause like i said
earlier about like people
loving japan now what do you think about
people who like like think of japan as a
utopia
like this kind of perfect society
because people give me [ __ ]
when i say like bad things about japan
like if you don't like it just leave i'm
like no no i'm just british i just
complain about everything
yeah sometimes i find it very
interesting like uh
like what is so great you know it's not
that japan has changed so much recently
it's just that
suddenly it's become a utopia so yeah um
i just think that japan is very unique
in even in asia like and there are a lot
of things that japan does originally
like you know anime
and j-rock and j-pop and all these uh
culture things that japan originally did
that is now um widespread in the world
so
um it's not that japan has changed or
anything it's just that um
those little things are being noticed
i guess it's just like it's also just
like the more like it's more exposure to
like
over glorification because because
now we know that japan does all of these
like unique things that are very
different to western countries
it's suddenly better quite unquote yeah
you know like yeah of course like there
are a lot of things about japan that are
just more
i don't know what is so i mean i love
matcha but i don't know what is
so like heavenly about macho do you like
matcha
i i do but i do i understand that it's
good but i don't know why
in america in america especially they
treat matcha like a brand of cocaine
japan does too japan has matcha
everything i'm pretty sure there's like
match a toilet
roll that you can eat no no but but no
but what i'm saying is that in america
there are so many things in america like
so many like even more in japan even if
it's a
hint of asian they're just like yeah
we're going to have much of something
no there's more i mean there there is
more matcha in japan
but like like what's up with the the way
that matcha is
like um marked it towards like the
americans it's like this exotic thing
it's a unique taste because matcha is
like an official frappuccino taste
yeah is it yeah like around the world
yeah around the world oh i didn't i
didn't know that
yeah yeah because you don't get
frappuccinos gone i'm the only one out
of the three of us that will get a
frappuccino
you've turned more white since you've
moved to japan
what it is gone it is what it is i just
think
that globally the world likes green
stuff like
wasabi it's green it's green
so if it's green it's probably cute
green
that's the only reason that i can come
up with green tea i mean
i mean that's kind of just much reason
that's all matcha is it's just tea
it's just green it's just green honestly
i i'm honestly i think marcia slaps and
i'll i'll be the one in the corner who
will defend marcia
don't get me wrong i like monsters
matcha is good
but it shouldn't be like
it shouldn't be like sold like this
is
so much is just like the tip of the
iceberg but there are so many things
about japan are
being discovered and are being like
utopia eyes so
like bidets should be yeah no yeah
exactly there are so there are a lot of
things about japan and japanese culture
that i think rightfully so
should be put up on a pedestal like
bidets for example right like
i mean [ __ ] you experience a bidet your
life has basically changed for the
better
as we discussed in an earlier heated
toilet seats heated toilet seats
japan has normalized heated toilet seats
great things about japan that you
find really like amazing i would like to
know about it okay for me
personally coming from sydney uh sydney
has one of the worst [ __ ] public
transport systems in the world
like it's i've discussed it in a podcast
before but like
just having coming to japan and being
like okay
the tr the schedule says the train's
coming at exactly 257
and the fact that i can go to the
platform at 2 56 and the train arrives
exactly one minute later is like
if if it came on time in australia you'd
think something was wrong
you think the bus driver had like a gun
to his head being like arrive here
on time because otherwise just never
comes on time
yeah there's there's two sides of japan
for me because i love
the convenience of japan but there's two
there's two sides of the convenience
because there's one
there's the daily living because just
living in japan
just the daily site daily living side of
japan it's so convenient it's so easy
and then there's the business side of
japan which is like the exact
opposite of convenience so i but like
just living here i
feel like i get the best the best of the
best of japan because i'm
self-employed so it's way more
convenient just to live here
it drives me insane that put like how
intensely they'll pursue
politeness here like to a point where it
makes everyone's life inconvenient
like it's gone saying about business
they'll they'll keep people in the chain
and of the business that shouldn't be in
the chain they'll be middlemen in
everything just out of like courtesy and
there's a point where i'm just like come
on this is ridiculous
like we can talk to about it ourselves
like no no you have to go through
the five middlemen who introduced them
to do i really need to get approval from
the boss's boss to just
go get some lunch yeah i just i just
want to go yeah i mean
but i mean the things i love uh i like
the safety
you know yeah yeah living in london it's
kind of sketchy at times
speaking of scheduling we've got to talk
about america right like oh right right
yeah new york to tokyo been like yeah
world apart and then also
you know being from the uk not known for
our culinary action
excellence um so it's nice having food
that tastes good all the time
at a reasonable price i'm scared because
you know i i was very good at eating
just like potato being like oh this is
amazing isn't it just a potato exactly
when you come to japan
you become really like gourmet
you expect everything to taste good and
you're like
to me pizza was anything with cheese
bread and tomato and i was pretty happy
with that yeah yeah but it was
anything with butter cheese on it is
good and then yeah now it's like is this
this is stone baked right now oh no oh
no
this is the locally grown locally grown
yeah yeah which prefecture are these
uh strawberries from oh really that
prefecture oh no no no no no no
taking order didn't cost a thousand
dollars for one strawberry get that out
of here
every time i go back to the uk now the
hardest thing i have to adjust to is
just going to like
go going through like my ubereats or the
local restaurant guide
like to my area and just seeing nothing
that's appealing to me
unless i travel all the way up to london
in the city takeout's really
good here yeah take out in the uk it's
like which greasy food do you want
yeah it's like you get a choice between
kebab kebab
pizza chicken burgers and i like chicken
burgers
i mean there's like i like chicken
burgers as well but there's a time and a
place for chicken burgers what about you
what's the best thing what's the best
thing of both like what do you like most
about america what do you like most
about japan
um well you know the thing that i i
liked about america was that it's really
diverse you know you could go anywhere
and really just feel at home
yeah yeah yeah too i really like it yeah
you can have conversations with anyone
yeah it's very open
but in japan you know it's hard to get
friendly with people i think it takes
time
people are more sort of shy and have
that one wall
yeah you feel like you have to break
down multiple barriers to like really
get to know someone and even then
it's quite hard to be able to call
someone a friend you know yeah yeah yeah
so that's one of the differences i feel
but
there are a lot of things i love about
japan as well you you feel safe
you know you can trust everyone most
most of the time yeah
yeah you can trust you know and the
quality is always you know
very high for anything not just food but
for any kind of service
or you know it's it's great but i think
that uh
you're sp you get spoiled in japan so
when once you start living in japan for
a while and you go overseas like
everything feels
slow everything feels you know like not
sub-optimized i almost understand why
some people just don't travel outside of
japan i'm like why would you
like what are you what are you gonna do
things just work here yeah and that's
what i love about japan
it's just everything you didn't think
about works
and then except for business the
business side but just like i said
everything
outside of that just perfectly works i
realized the london underground was i
mean
i knew it was dirty i didn't realize it
was that dirty until you go like
i knew that i knew that you get you get
like the you know you get the railway to
the airport in japan
it's ultra clean you get in your plane
you get home you have to get the
underground to go home you're like oh
god there's
[ __ ] everywhere well i mean you're from
new york right now new york city
it's just like another level i i you
know i normally feel safe on
public transport but the underground the
subway in new york really tested
my ability to feel safe yeah but even in
the
music industry like concert wise i
realized there was a huge difference
like when i went to um
san jose to do my first concert like you
know it was american style concert so
yeah
um we were already used to doing the
japanese style and we went to the the
venue
and then it was lunchtime so um in japan
you know even if it's lunchtime if
there's a lot of work done or you know
it
no one just strays off you know goes
yeah
lunch break or anything and everyone
like if you have an hour that means you
have about 30 minutes right after like
clean up and everything but yeah
back in the states um it was 12 o'clock
everyone disappeared
and then no one was there so the
japanese team was there uh waiting you
know
it was like oh what do we do and then
we're okay so lunch break is one hour so
at one o'clock we come back and we do
rehearsals again
so we were we were planning on that but
then like
the camera people and the lighting
people like didn't appear for another
hour or so
that sounds like an american but the
amazing thing is
even though they don't like you know do
all that preparation stuff
yeah like the the show boom
they they do their thing they do their
thing they don't need rehearsal
they just um they do their thing god
damn that's i i
if most conventions i've been to there
have been like technical difficulties on
like
every every panel that i've posted
a technical difficulty
that's that's you know you know that's
how the world works and japan is just
very
you know perfectionism they're just like
a little
too over cautious at times where it's
like why are you stressing out about
this
you don't have to have 17 rehearsals
like exactly
how many rehearsals do you have for a
japanese concert uh
it depends on the event but we do all
definitely we do a lot of rehearsals
beforehand and we'll do like like before
the shows um we go through like it's
called
genipro but it's a rehearsal where you
do it exactly
like so basically just a dress rehearsal
yeah the show
exactly how it's done and you probably
need to do that two or three times
audio so when you perform a concert
you're not just performing it once
you're performing it like four times
exactly in secret most of the time when
it's a big big
uh the last time that counts
going back like a million topics going
back to the
exactly i'm really intrigued about the
whole anime opening you know process
how do you so from complete start to
finish like how do you get the like call
where you're like hey
this is a show it needs an opening how
does that all go and then how does the
process go like
you you write it you know i just want to
know everything about it because i feel
like we haven't actually like yeah yeah
talk about the process to be a waste not
yeah i think it depends on the artist
but um if you pr if you're like uh
signed with an
anime-based label yeah then
there are a lot of like types that need
artists so they're always looking for it
and it depends if
you are the one that sort of offers or
they offer for you
it depends on the situation but once you
sort of uh get an offer or you
get a you go grab an offer then
that sort of starts into the songwriting
creation and then
you write all of it yeah you have to
make it from zero usually
okay so um that begins there and i wrote
all the lyrics for my
songs not all the melodies but um all
the lyrics
do they give you any input on any of
that like that do you have like any
source material
do you write around that or is it just
usually we start writing when
the series isn't um complete yet so we
only get like
a really brief um description
so what was it like for something like
batum what do they say just like oh
batoon was actually a manga before the
enemy so that really helped
you read all the manga you read the
manga and you
sort of uh they also have hints like
this kind of song or that kind of song
and then
um you try to fulfill their expectations
there
but batum for example no pain no game we
had a lot of freedom with that song
right so uh they really probably didn't
expect that kind of
sort of
and so uh but everyone really like so it
stood out in a good way i think
it stood out and um they were like wow
we weren't expecting this in a good
i mean i think i can speak on behalf of
the anime community being like
most people if not all people only
remember the opening difficulty
so is that like a a one take here's a
song i'm done or is it like they
constantly are always
like ah can you change this can you
change this can we try this sometimes um
they have very like uh
detailed sort of descriptions for what
they want but sometimes it's just
completely free
so with batum though we had a lot of
freedom so we didn't have to
adjust or redo a lot of things but for
other songs for example
there are a couple of um
retakes or recreations or
there are some songs that i've done i've
written
that have completely disappeared okay
right right
so when you do an anime opening who who
owns the rights
to that song is it the did the anime
people just get like a license to use it
in the anime and you retain everything
or like how does that work
if you know it might be the label right
that's probably the label
yeah you're just like i don't know i
make music the label has the song
right and so um when the song is used
the
the rights belong to the leader because
i think flying dog was like it can
correct me if i'm wrong it's like a
major label that
was primarily focused on like more anime
music so like
a lot of like anime like osts and like
openings were usually
started and owned by that record label
so like um i like how you're looking at
connor like he's going to know what
you're talking about
because you probably don't know
because like i was again like i was
reading your wikipedia and you know
flying dog and stuff like that i did a
bit of research
because i was always interested in as
well of like how i guess like
rights and like distribution works for
anime songs because i feel it's
completely different to like an artist
just
releasing their own yeah i always wanted
because you know a lot of the songs
wouldn't have you know wouldn't blow up
without the animated back of it so i
wondered if there's a system that like
there was like co-ownership or like
i'm just pretty intrigued i didn't know
if you knew yeah it's it's very
complicated like the rights thing is
just
is just sounds like a nightmare yeah
i've always had issues
like youtube issues with like rights and
it's always a mess yeah
in japan everything about the rights is
huge you know like you can't say
certain stuff on tv yeah um you you need
permission for a lot of things yeah
we've experienced
it so japan [ __ ] do you have
permission hell
it's just like never ending the approval
chain is just
[ __ ] a mile long i never like there
are so many things
it's like since working with japanese
companies did i
notice i was like oh you needed approval
for that
because it was the first time um that i
had that i experienced
like taking off a label off a water
bottle
like in america i never even thought
about that yeah
i openly drink heavy on water so you
know
like taking the labels off like at
events or like
that is completely japanese culture
right i noticed that the first time
actually when i was watching like a
japanese tv show and i noticed that
the water bottle on like the desk or
whatever was like
mosaiced out and i'm like what the [ __ ]
are they drinking
[Music]
how bad is this is this hentai water i'm
drinking like lolly water i've seen this
i mean they'll show you shots on tv and
it'll be like shibuya
everything is blurred yeah except for
like two people walking yeah
why are you even showing
it's odd because then two seconds later
it'll cut to a shot where everything's
shown and i'm like
there is no consistency on this i'm so
confused
you know there must be some rights going
on where it's completely flip-flopping
and uh yeah i don't know it's bizarre
how did it feel like the first time you
watched an anime and just
heard yourself singing before the anime
started oh
it was really nerve-wracking um i was
probably
peeing my pants because you're
pretty much living the dream that i
think a lot of like especially like
western weebs one where they're like
yeah i can sing one day i'm gonna sing
in an anime opening
like it's very surreal it's very surreal
it didn't really like hit home until a
lot later
yeah because do you i assume when you
are producing the song you don't
actually get to see
the animation opening
well actually i did see like a a sample
of the opening but the first time i
actually saw the official like
finalized version was on tv right so it
was probably like the same as you guys
yeah right i was like in front of the
screen i was like what the hell
what the hell is happening i hear my
voice from the tv
do you normally escape out of my
openings in my life um i usually well
yeah i mean i don't think there's
anything wrong with skipping anime
openings yeah i said
it i [ __ ] said it because sometimes
they're kind of mid yeah
let's let's be honest as an artist right
when you when netflix gives you that
skip in
intro button does your heart like die
inside a little bit you're like oh my
hard work
i try to not imagine how many people are
skipping
like how do you skip my bang a song
because now that you work in the
industry has that changed the way you
kind of like
not only view anime music but just music
in general because
like as someone who works in anime
youtube i can't look at anime youtubers
the same or like i can't view it
as just uh to be entertained anymore i i
can't shut off that part of my brain i
think it has sort of destroyed a bit
of like the enjoyment part of it because
everything i
that concerns like music right now
becomes a job for me
so i i start listening to like you know
i
it's hard to just listen it for my
enjoyment yeah i do find it because
sometimes you you see someone who just
does something [ __ ] great and you're
just like
damn it i wish i did that i wish i could
do that
yeah i get that every time i'm just like
why didn't i come up with that
yeah yeah exactly right exactly it's
like i love this video
except for the fact that i didn't make
it yeah like i wish i'd have made that
yeah i mean i love you you're going to
do it yeah
but this person did it before me yeah
god damn i hate this person bye
[ __ ] respect they totally stole the
idea that was just in my head
is that like a i guess like very general
question is there like a japanese artist
that you would ever want to like
collaborate with in the future
oh there are so many but especially
recently
i feel that i want to do more
collaborations and
so you know um
like there are a lot of artists though
yeah yeah i i
think i don't think we asked like who
are some artists that you like
or respect japanese japanese or western
yeah japanese or western well you know
right up down the top up to that no but
i do i do really respect your music
but also like artists like miyavi oh
yeah yeah
oh but one amazing thing that happened
this recently is i collaborated on stage
with flo
oh wow oh that was a real dream come
true for me yeah
so um that was amazing because that you
know i was a listener
of theirs um how did that happen i have
no idea
i woke up and i was collaborating on
stage with the flow no
no but um it was an event okay and it
was an event
um and we the event side
said that hey it would be great if you
collaborated on a cover song
with flo which was uh sambun
which was a runoni kenshin anime opening
so um that was amazing but the thing is
we met for the first time during the
only rehearsal
that was happened right before the
actual
stage so that that we didn't have a lot
of time
to uh you know get to know each other
but it was amazing and these kind of
miracles do happen when you're
working like this so um you know that's
exciting
that's always exciting it seems like you
you've just
had a lot of great opportunities that
you never kind of like aim for it just
kind of happens
that definitely i i'd have to say that a
lot of the miracles that happened
uh were unexpected next step for you
though is collaborating with avro levine
[Music]
let's see if we can make it happen
so i have to ask do you watch any
youtubers
i have made a youtube watching debut so
um i'm just a newbie right now so i'm
starting to search for good channels
and i actually um i'm planning to start
my own channel as well all right oh
okay i'm sort of studying right now i'm
watching you guys
well
cosplay badly what are you doing youtube
channel um just
mostly like half of the things i plan to
do are going to be music based but half
of the things are going to be like just
for fun just for you know having fun
with my watchers
and me being me yeah so yeah any advice
oh that's a that's a loaded question
right there
clickbait
yeah titles and thumbnails are like your
bread and butter yeah
if you don't know what do you recommend
okay actually i'll tell you what you
could do
anime opening singer reacts to anime
openings
tell me that's not going to do well
professional anime openings
yeah that would actually do really well
really well
okay this is why this is a good anime
opening yeah this is why this is a bad
anime opening and like you can because
you have the authority to say that right
as someone who's made
as someone who's made multiple animes
well what are some of your favorite
anime openings
if you'd if you can say that i really do
enjoy
like you know like i said full metal
alchemist i mostly like
all their songs and just
i'm a i'm a rock artist so i like rock
based songs a lot
and yes do you just listen to the music
or do you
do you pay attention to like the actual
visuals and animation with it as well or
you're just like okay this is a good
song i like the song
i think first i'll listen to the song
and then i'll watch the
visuals but then i end up just listening
to the song itself so
yeah that's me as well i feel that's the
case it's like
yeah if you just like especially as well
like if you like a song you
at least for me i'm like oh never heard
of this artist before i'm gonna
delve into everything else that they
have and then nine times out of ten you
realize
yeah there's probably a reason why
they're known for this song but i think
you know i do think
youtube is about being real and so i i
want to do
what i plan to do is to show like behind
the scenes stuff of a lot of the music
industry like what i can't
what there's there is a limit to what i
can show but i
will try to show you know some of the
down and dirty stuff you know that
people don't know about like in the
recording studio or like
behind the stage in my concert yeah yeah
and all these things and so i think i'm
i really want to
just show people what the music industry
is about
yeah because what made you want to start
youtube because this is very different
from
the image we talked about earlier of
just like you know the mysterious nano
exactly the opposite of what i've been
doing yeah yeah yeah
so is you was is it just you just trying
to find something new trying to do
something different
that too but also it's just that i feel
that it's it's
it's more fitting in the generation to
not be perfect like right up until now
everything about
music was being you know perfect but in
this generation it's solely
about showing what's not perfect yeah
and people are more interested in the
imperfections of you know the
entertainment industry so
hopefully i can i've you know been
singing for years and i have seen you
know
behind the scenes stuff so to share that
with the world
yeah that'd be super interesting yeah
because i feel that's like a very unique
position to be in as well like we can't
just rock up to like
a concert of yours and being like hey
we're backstage right now this is what
it looks like
without going through leaps and hurdles
of you know approval and stuff like that
and i do feel that that's a big reason
why youtube has grown
so large in recent years is because
people feel a connection with youtubers
because they see the imperfections
they see that they're not this perfect
idol or perfect artist that
you know we a lot of us came up from the
same background and i know you did as
well
but it's it might be hard for someone to
like relate to that when they don't know
all the intimate details of your
background and
where you came up from so yeah that it
was very interesting hearing your story
today
i mean sometimes it is scary to think
that you know showing people like you
know the
sort of like the mistakes and stuff with
the
recording city and stuff but yeah at the
same time i think that there are not a
lot of artists who are willing to share
that side
yeah so um you know i'm going to throw
him up throw away my pride and
uh try to be real with people you know
show that you know
recording does take a lot of effort
there's a lot of you know um
mistakes and redos and you know it's
just effort effort effort after effort
and then
the cd is created so it's not just you
know you sing it you record it you
put it together i'd be surprised there's
many people out there who actually think
that that it's just like nails
i mean there might be some just amazing
people who nail it and you know just
but it's just you know it's real life so
um i'd love to be able to share that
started that sort of effort with people
you know
how much effort does go into making one
song and
one concert and so you know hopefully
people will find that interesting
and i might you know do a few weird
parodies
oh yeah yeah
hopefully your channel will be ready by
the time this episode
yeah if it is links in the description
so he's like
when were you planning to debut your
channel um march
14th i think or march somewhere around
there so hopefully
uh it'll be ready before that and then
yeah people
can sort of maybe click on it so if her
channel is
up and ready it's gonna that you can
click on the link in the description to
subscribe to nano and uh i guess that
will be a week
after this episode airs so keep an eye
out on that for that as well
you're really at home right now so maybe
i can just uh
just park here yeah yeah it could be the
fourth
fourth of july he could be one of the
boys
i think i need a trash taste opening
so maybe after this time i'm gonna like
just happen to appear every time you
know
like fourth fourth yeah definitely well
we'd love to have you back on sometime i
would love to be
back i think you know if you're gonna be
a youtuber you should do our outro for
us that's a very crucial part
like an outro song no no no no outro for
the youtube video you know you have to
say like like comment subscribe
oh yeah you got to you got to get used
to that all right
youtuber youtuber coaching session right
now okay so
all you have to do is look at the camera
and go hope you guys enjoyed the video
be sure to like comment and smash the
like button you have to stay smashed
you can't you can't just say you like
hit the like button it has to be like
smash the like
button holding the smash the like button
can i practice here yeah go go go go go
ahead
everyone watching youtube thank you that
was nano you have to
smash the like button
and if you're if you're like us you have
patrons who are watching right now and
yeah
patreons look at all these lovely
pictures it's amazing
so much patreon
uh i'll help you practice the apology
video as well
we'll go through that but yeah if you
guys would like to support the show then
make sure to go over to patreon.com
uh trash taste also yeah i almost forgot
our own patreon
url also follow us on twitter the
subreddit and listen to us over on
spotify and of course go check out
everything
uh on
where can you find me instagram twitter
what do you have instagram spotify
twitter spotify uh instagram uh
youtube yeah all those links will be in
the description down below
so make sure that you smash them smash
those links to smash
the like button but yes thank you very
much for coming on nano
thank you very insightful yes i don't
know if what i said
is you know any any
[Laughter]
thank you so as well i can much know
join you guys again
yeah definitely absolutely i will
definitely be going to one of your
concerts eventually thank you
yeah when when for sure when you are
back performing again so if you see one
loud gaijin in the back it's gonna
probably be me
if you see three loud guys and you guys
will of course join me backstage
of course of course i mean of course it
was implied right
of course but obviously i would love to
bring to collaborate with you guys on
youtube someday dude that'd be awesome
yeah yeah but yes that's been this
episode of trash taste hope you guys
enjoyed it and we will see you all
next time bye
[Music]
you